michel vaujour court toujours michel
vaujour s'est échappé hier matin de la
prison de la santé
la belle la plus spectaculaire la belle
par le chemin des verts l'évasion en
hélicoptère c'est sa propre femme on en
est sûr maintenant qui pilotait
l'hélicoptère mais pour l'instant
vaujour et sa femme sont introuvables
le point de l'anc est tout de suite
c'est ici même sur cette passerelle
proche de la cité universitaire co
michel vaujour un complice et la femme
qui pilotait l'hélicoptère ont été vues
pour la dernière fois
vingt-quatre heures après l'évasion
aucune trace des trois fuyards
seul élément nouveau dans l' enquête
l'identité du pilote c'est nadine
bourdin la propre femme de michel
vaujour qui était aux commandes de 7
alouettes 2 le coup était parfaitement
préparée depuis dix mois
nadine bourdin prenait des leçons de
pilotage dans le seul but de faire
évader son mari cette femme de 35 ans
n'est pas une inconnue des policiers
mariés depuis sept ans avec michel
vaujour elle avait déjà été interpellé
en 1983 en juillet de cette année-là un
hold up sanglant à tour deux malfaiteurs
tué dont le propre frère de nadine et
deux convoyeurs de fonds blessé hier
matin nadine bourdin alias l'ena rigon
s'est présenté tranquillement à saint
cyr l'école pour louer un hélicoptère
quelques minutes plus tard comme un as
du pilotage elle enlevait son mari sous
les yeux des gardiens médusés